- Just to let you know that
the flight time's going to be roughly
a minute and twenty seconds today.
(engine revving)
- [Narrator] This is
Westray Island Airport.
And this is Papa Westray Island Airport.
They're only 1.7 miles
away from each other
and are connected by the world's
shortest commercial flight.
The average flying time
is about 80 seconds.
These two islands are a part of the
Orkney Islands in Northern Scotland.
This archipelago is defined
by jagged coastlines,
and its obvious lack of trees.
There are 70 islands in total,
only 20 of them are inhabited.
On some islands, like Papa Westray,
the population is less than 100.
To get around up here most people fly
on this plane, the
inter-island Loganair route.
Colin here, he's the head pilot.
- I'm Colin McAllister,
I'm the senior pilot.
The aircraft we fly in Orkney,
it carries 8 passengers.
The highest that we've reached
would be about 350 feet altitude.
So it's quite low.
It flies at around about 150 miles an hour
and it has the aerodynamics of a brick,
but it is super for what
we do in the islands.
- [Narrator] So why
does this flight exist?
Because there are so few
people in the Orkney Islands,
building bridges doesn't
make financial sense,
they just wouldn't get enough use.
So, if you live up here,
there are only two ways to get around.
One, you can take this ferry,
which is super, super slow.
Or, two, you can fly.
- My name is Kate,
and I live on Orkney mainland,
but I fly out to several of the islands
teaching music on a weekly basis.
Once every three weeks
I'm flying the shortest
flight to get to work.
- The flight is used
almost like a bus service.
- [Narrator] It acts like a bus route,
but it's not.
It takes a team,
from the two air traffic controllers,
- Okay, you're clear to land.
- [Narrator] To the four firefighters,
they all work together to
help keep the flight safe.
- [Colin] Over the years I've flown
somewhere between four
and five thousand times
between Westray and Papa Westray.
It is community spirit that drives
the people who work at the airfields.
- [Narrator] The world's shortest flight
has been around for a long time.
- This year I've been flying it
for 50 years in Orkney.
- [Narrator] At this point
it's a well-oiled machine.
Our only complaint?
No drink service.